[Music]
you fancy out here stop stop I'm a
simple boy from Ohio SME decided to
seize Nick I'm excited to see Taylor
Swift I've never seen her perform live
but she's like she's not baby but she's
a you know yeah collab
does she watch this she like hey Taylor
baby if you're watching this I would
love to make a video with you one day
you know I'll see what happens maybe
take you to dinner
what would the video entail between you
and Taylor Swift's who knows man I mean
we'd show up we kind of Griff rap maybe
make a song hot a song a 20-18 probably
most definitely
and then we what I don't know get
married or something chill like that
you're the boyfriend now you know what
they say about boyfriends what do they
say I'm Logan Paul you make so many
videos and so many vlogs this year Oh
everyday kind of crazy and wild and fun
a favorite do you have a favorite oh I
don't know I here's the thing so I make
the vlogs every day and then like I kind
of forget what happened because I'm so
focused on the vlog but I mean you know
I've had crazy ones I got my bus
customized I I bought a new g wagon for
before squared they're just they're just
amazing I'm few wagons Gucci Gucci
jackets that cause way too much money
video topics that you've not covered
that we will never see you touch upon
like things that you want to keep off
the internet oh so I make jokes but to
be honest I keep my like personal like
dating life I try to keep it private
I like it doesn't always happen actually
like ever but like I try I try why is
that important to you to keep it quiet
as quiet as possible just cuz like I
don't know my side chairs getting mad at
my main chick and like my main chick
called me off having side chicks like
it's just like it gets confusing
I'll begin to play pro before you go you
want to reach in and pick a question out
of our et Santa snapback snap oh you
can't wear it though do you wanna pick a
question good question okay okay I got
it
are you on the naughty or nice list this
year and why no honey I'm on the naughty
list
come on yo why do you say that I'm a
freak your boys crazy next year maybe
you'll be on the nice list probably not
do you want to pick another one yeah
who do you okay who do you plan to kiss
under the mistletoe this season you got
a mistletoe stumble upon it I don't know
man
to me it's like if my dog happened to
walk under it like Oh kiss Kong Kong if
you're watching this I'll kiss you baby
[Music]